i never seen you before
you're not puerto rican
is that okay this movie
is a movie that redefines all movies
it's incredible and you're all
incredible so congratulations and i'm
going to start with you the queen rita
first of all
yeah okay
all right
what can i do for you
shut
up
what you have been doing for us for the
past 60 years i wondered if somebody had
told you 60 years ago that you would be
sitting with this cast in this moment
and i know you have said i originally
wanted to ask you what it was like to
win an academy award but i heard you say
it's really about the work so i want to
know working on this how profound was it
for you because valentina
has such a pivotal role in this movie
how profound and deep was it how deeply
did it can i explain briefly who she is
so that the audience knows what i'm
talking about valentina is the widow
of doc the man who used to run the candy
store where the jets hung out
now the question as to
what huh i'm old
how about what wasn't experienced how
profound was this for you like how
deeply did it resonate the actual work i
heard that you made the cast cry in a
table read when you sang a certain song
in the film
and yes everybody's nodding that that's
true but then there's shots behind the
scenes of you dancing with the jets and
the sharks so just you can talk about
that experience
it's been it's been the rarest and most
sublime experience of of my life and
that it would come at 90 because i will
be 90 in a few days from here from now
uh it's it's sublime
it's thrilling
it's weird it's uh there's something
insanely
strange and rare about doing a scene
with anita
when she almost gets assaulted in the
candy store scene because i remember
that very clearly that i remember
bursting into tears when i shot it
because it opened up so many wounds that
i never even knew
had not healed so
i i have been through the gamut
of every kind of emotion you can imagine
and then to be in it again
and to have a role written by tony
kushner who i think is only brilliant
and has made this
in the best possible way
more clear
uh
more socially minded film than it was
before
uh is extraordinary i could go on but i
know you would love to talk to other
people
i would love to talk to you for hours
though as well um i'm gonna be arranged
but not today okay okay because i have
so many questions rachel you're maria i
think for anybody who's been on youtube
and has seen you know some of the
original productions either in school or
local would say you were born to play
this role and i wrote down the words in
the screening magic because you are pure
magic on screen just astonishing but i'm
wondering for you because you did play
this role before
how much working on the film version did
maria evolve for you and who is maria to
you now
yeah i mean maria was so wildly
different from what i think anyone has
probably seen her as before you know you
go back to the source material she's
juliette capulet she's virginal and
naive and doesn't really have much
agency
um and as she evolved in the 57 original
play the 61 film
she kind of remained that engineer
part that didn't have as much depth and
i know that it was very important to
tony kushner to incorporate the
historical context of what was really
going on for her at the time and i got
pages and pages of backstory from him
about her mother and her father and how
long she's been in the country and who
who actually wanted her to come to the
states and that was actually anita who
convinced bernardo to bring her to new
york and i just remember
having this conversation with stephen on
the first day of rehearsals and and
saying i just want to do a good job and
he said are you scared and i said of
course i'm scared and he said use that
and um and i did and i think it made a
world of difference she's not sure of
herself but she is
very strong-minded and she's not afraid
to stand up to bernardo she's not afraid
to stand up to tony she's not afraid to
stand up to anita and i think it's a
really cool thing for young women to see
in a latina role that has constantly be
seen we've
constantly been seen as just a very
silent virginal engineer
did you i heard that you manifested
getting this role what do you
specifically do to manifest asking for a
friend
i'm pretty sure the public just thinks i
tweet and then it just comes true
um that's that's really what it is no i
i i visualize and i put good out and i i
truly believe in the universe and
putting good out getting good back in
and just
sharing the love and i a little bird
told me that when you were just
finishing shrek the musical when you got
the role can you just tell me about that
moment where you said can i finish the
musical
yeah i actually just been cast in shrek
when i got cast in west side story and
it was my senior year musical and that
place that school cultivated my love of
what i get to do for a living now and so
one of the first words out of my mouth
when steven told me i got the part was
is it okay if i finish my senior musical
and he moved the schedule around for me
it was very sweet
[Laughter]
it was the most uh the high most highly
anticipated high school musical i think
uh in new jersey so
i saw it yeah ansel saw it ansel came to
see
i mean before she comes on stage it's
like a high school musical and then she
comes on stage and the energy in the
theater is like
boom it's just so big and it's past the
back row and it was like seeing lebron
james
like the highlights of him playing high
school basketball where it was like
totally unfair and it's like he's gonna
go
that's what it was like watching rachel
do sharks
wow very sweet that's my best review
that i've ever gotten you will forever
be compared to lebron james that's the
best analogy i've ever heard a million
years that i think i'd get compared to
an athlete but here we are height
difference slight height difference
i'll go to you i think one of the most
important things in watching this film
is you really have to believe the love
story between the two of them because
this is truly what it's about it's it
everything around
hinges on that belief and when i watched
the two of you together in that
gymnasium scene i had this moment if it
reminded me of the first time and
hopefully everybody's had this moment in
their life when you see somebody and you
instantly know your life has changed
forever and i'm wondering how you two
created that together like did you how
did you
how did you work on that on creating
that moment
well i mean we we had a lot of time i
know that this isn't a love at first
sight kind of thing but we had a lot of
time together
you know mutual respect admiration
and
like you know time to bond throughout
making you know rehearsal yeah but
also
you know there's you have to also give
credit to
yanush and steven and also the writing
of it all because the and the dancers in
between you and the costumes and
everything tells that story and makes
you really feel that love the first time
that's the romance the romance is
everything happening around us truly
that's what makes it dramatic and
dangerous but i felt like there was
something i guess this is just from me
from tony like in terms of character
when there's something about maria that
just feels like
good
and in this world where like there's so
much like roughness and like kind of bad
characters and like a dark history for
tony like he sees this girl and she's so
clearly just like
there's just goodness and maybe it is
also just the white dress
and then when they do like go under the
bleachers like she
yeah this this is clearly like this is
what's going to turn everything around
this is what's going to lead to that
path of goodness because that's where
tony wants to go now did i hear that the
fire escape scene you improvised you
weren't supposed to
sorry interruptions
you were supposed to climb up but then
you climbed up anyway no yeah no it it
was just that when we you know they're
always trying to be really safe and
stuff so when we were in washington
heights and there it was like the
outside fire escape yeah it was like
don't start climbing it but i couldn't
help myself and i loved climbing so i
just started climbing the fire escape
and then they ended up using it and that
was my real reaction of being like no no
no no
and if that take is hilarious and he
just pulls himself up it's kind of
hysterical
because it's a bit of an unguarded
moment because so much of the
musical is so like the scenes are so
choreographed and it felt a little bit
raw and a little bit spontaneous so i
was happy to find out that that was a
spontaneous moment um ariana oh my
goodness
your performance is
extraordinary and the america scene is
something by first of all the way it was
shot but you're dancing in it and that's
one thing that this film really got so
right is the athleticism of all of you
and the dancing what was most important
to you about bringing to life this role
of anita you know with this fabulous
woman sitting next to you and i know you
two had a lunch maybe at the beginning
of filming
and what did you talk about
and then you had this amazing scene
together you know this amazing scene
together that was again such a seminal
moment in the movie
if you could talk about all of it
basically
i was like
let me prioritize those answers um you
know i don't really
i think when when i really
think about you know what now lives on
the screen
i would say i'm most proud that
she is a very different anita like our
anitas are not the same like they have
the same characteristics they both are
women who know their mind they have
agency they speak their mind they have
you know goals dreams ambition all of
that but we are inherently different
than he does and i'm really proud of
that
i would say that i truly enjoyed the
dancing
um because that's what i'm built to do
it was built to be a triple threat um
and to example threats
yeah i suppose i don't what's the what
is the fourth
what's that personality my sparkling
personality and my humor
no but i i you know justin peck and his
team did an incredible job not only
paying homage to the original robert's
choreography but
to create his own language his own
curriculum
of of steps and moves it is a full
language and you can see the the through
line through the movement that he
created for the jets and the movement
that he created with the sharks um it's
it's really something to behold and
quite frankly a herculean task to
to do
um so i'm really proud of what
specifically you see in america
um
because it's a beautiful beautiful
portrayal of this community and the way
that dance is used it's just another way
that the audience gets to know exactly
who we are as puerto ricans and i love
that
and you know if i'm if i may interrupt
one second because it's so important
justin peck for those who don't know the
name is the name of our choreographer
he's from the new york city ballet
imagine imagine
having to deal with
the jerome robbins choreography and say
okay
how do i not top this necessarily but
how do i equal this
what do i do i i'm astonished at him i
think he did a genius job
of placing his own imprimatur
on the choreography of this astonishing
movie i wanted to ask both um
ariana and rita what did you learn from
each other on set and maybe in that
lunch that you had um
what did we learn from each other not a
damn thing
i have absolutely nothing to offer let's
just be real about it it's okay but it's
a it's a nice question but really
to me it does it's not a question that
can be answered i would say
for
for me
uh you lead by example you just sort of
are you are this force of nature that
comes onto a set and the way that you
work
i learned a lot from watching how you
work
um
also strong women in the entertainment
industry can frequently be called
difficult women for simply speaking
their mind and i really enjoyed watching
how rita navigates a set and how she
communicates with a director or a dp
when she asks for what she needs you
know and i think
those examples are what you know lead
the way for
change and getting women into positions
of power because we're not difficult
it's not difficult when you ask for what
you need
it simply is you know yeah
i'm very grateful for for that example
that's lovely well i can only tell you
that she is a ariana
is a
a ferocious dancer in the best sense of
the word
you well you saw it so you know
she's extraordinary
and the truth is that she's
way
far more superior dancer than i was
because when i auditioned for this role
i hadn't danced in years and years and
years number one number two i'd never
done this kind of dance which is
interestingly enough called jazz
i was a spanish dancer i did incredible
heel work and i did the arms and all
that but i didn't know how to dance
that kind of dance
so uh you know seeing her
just absolutely
revivifying all of this is thrilling i
love watching her
[Music]
you know i wake up to everything i know
either getting sold or wrecked or being
taken over by people that i don't like
first of all you too
opposite each other and you know i was
asking
about the sort of the love aspect of
this film but you two are you know of
course your
leaders of rival gangs how did you two
create
those sort of moments because i think in
the original they talked about how both
sides were sort of kept apart on set
how did you guys create that tension
i think there's a love story here i
don't know what you're talking about
something we're not willing to accept so
we go through all that fuss and trouble
yeah a little offended quite frankly i
don't know what animosity you are
getting from this film but uh
uh no i i i know
for me it was i think pretty easy man
it was easy and i don't like you yeah
it's nice
it's that easy and i think we what
helped a lot was that we had this
ensemble backing us up kind of like
being there for us
um and kind of guiding us through this
journey of what we're supposed to do as
the leaders of these gangs
um i thought i don't know i remember
when we shot the rumble scene
um
which was like a whole week of night
shoots i just remember the intensity in
that room every day but it wasn't
it wasn't like i hated you or you hated
me or the sharks hated the jets it was
just
intense and we all were feeling this um
these emotions and we were all there in
the moment present and i mean we were
all doing we all knew that we were doing
this thing together yeah and i think
like
especially for the rumble
david and i had rehearsed this knife
fight and like choreographed it for
months now and we had been working on it
and it was just like okay here's the
moments of doing it and
um
you know i i think i told you this but
it's like that moment i know i'm like
spoiling it for someone that has never
seen west side before but like
there's a knife fight and i'm like
something that bad things happen
and
but there's that moment you know when
that thing happens and like we're
looking at each other
and uh
i mean it's like a realization of
wait i don't actually hate you i just
yeah i'm scared i'm scared of losing my
territory i'm scared of losing my family
it's just
it's almost realizing that it's not
personal it's we're both afraid and this
is how we deal with our fears yeah and
there was like this commonality and this
understanding
between the two characters in that
moment in that particular moment at
least when i was like looking at you in
that moment i was like
oh that's when the love happens that's
when the love happened yes
but it really was like an acceptance and
like oh i i see you for who you are wow
it was interesting it was very
interesting yeah i'll never forget that
moment i never thought it would it was
gonna end up being like that it was just
something that happened in that moment
and we kind of just rolled with it
because you had your realization i had
my realization and we were just both
like
well this is it this is what our
mistakes have led us to well i had heard
david for you like i know so many people
auditioned there was like an open call
they actually went after you you were
like off the grid somewhere and you like
came to like a facebook message
and they sought you out for this role
and then on top of that you needed to
gain weight so you had milkshakes and
fried chicken and i want to know how i
have your life how does this happen like
how
i have no idea um i just
i think
it
it's so hard to explain it just kind of
happened just like it just kind of
happened to you i don't think
any of us really thought that we would
be doing this right now and i think
it just the opportunity presented itself
and we just gave it what we had in our
hearts and that was that happened to be
what they were looking for yeah and i
think
i think it's as simple as that you know
i don't think they were chasing me you
know so it's not about that i think
um
i was just
so excited to be able to like start
working on this character and and start
bringing this to life
um
so for me it was
it just kind of
unfolded itself naturally and i was
trying to keep up with what was
unfolding mike one last question before
we get wrapped i know you guys you both
talked about how the rehearsal process
was the most beautiful experience of
your lives i think and that intense like
the steven spielberg of it all but the
first day you filmed after all that when
you actually
they said action for the first time what
was that moment like
did it feel different than rehearsals
it was an extension of it wasn't
actually like different it was like uh
okay
now we're just gonna be here and you're
gonna wear these things and
we're just
gonna do what we've been doing um which
up to this point we've just we were just
we were just
doing the work we were just um getting
to know ourselves and our tribes and
spending time with each other
and doing our work and so when it came
to
okay action
it was just an extension of that you
know and it didn't stop that process
didn't stop i that's how i feel yeah
absolutely i mean i feel like for me was
a little bit different because
i felt like
i was definitely nervous
until
it was like all right action and then
once the action it's like all the nerves
out the window
all the worries out the window i was
there and i was president like that's
why i like
when
it should be like the opposite i should
be nervous when they when they say
action but like for me i'm nervous in
life
and then
yeah like i'm nervous in in normal life
and then
once they sell act you know say action
it's like oh i can be now who i want to
be so it's interesting
[Music]
[Applause]
if you go with him no one will ever
forgive you
first of all it's my understanding that
you described making this film as the
apogee of joy something that you almost
cannot put into words can you explain
why and how that was that it was your
best experience in ct
it was my best experience since et
because on et
it was a small family and a family that
just
did just there was such fidelity inside
that family i became a i wanted to be i
want to be a dad for the first time
because of e.t
but having now being a dad of seven kids
and five grandkids with a six on the way
um i found another family only a very
large extended family a family of of the
hispanic let let the next experience
a family of actors and technicians and
art artists in every single department
and it was a joyful experience to put so
many dance numbers on the screen
that made me feel i mean i probably
dropped 25 years i i can't dance to save
my life but i was dancing inside every
day on those sets with all those amazing
performing artists vocal artists
the the the art of choreography
the art of of of just just
such great actors and i really felt that
that by the time west side story was
over just like i felt on et i did not
want to do that last shot i did not want
to have to say cut print and it's a wrap
on the i'll tell you a story on the last
shot rita moreno came to me and said can
i stew the slate because i did this late
for the robert wise west side story he
let me slate the last shot can i slate
your last shot and i said absolutely but
it was the last shot
and so rita was standing by with the
slate i did the first take
she came and she slated it
but i didn't want the film to end
so i made rita go out 14 more times
unnecessarily
to slate the last shot before i finally
threw in the towel and said okay that's
it we're done
i never wanted to be done with that
movie wow well i know the 10 year old
you was brought the broadway album for
the first time it meant so much to you
um after the last frame in the film
before the credits rolled it's just said
to dad can you sort of explain that well
that was to my father my father loved
west side story he always he wanted to
see the movie he didn't live to see my
west side story our our west side story
um but he always asked me about it and
he was 103 and a half when he passed
when i was shooting the movie when he
was like 101 and a half he was in a
wheelchair in los angeles i was shooting
in new york but he was on the ipad
constantly on facetime and they'd hold
the ipad up and my dad would watch us
shoot a lot of the scenes and he just
loved it so much and i didn't get the
film finished in time to show him
and he passed so i thought well the next
best thing i can do
is dedicate it to my father who i so
deeply loved yeah and that's why it says
four dad at the end beautiful what was
the song that ten-year-old stephen was
belting out the most at the dinner table
at the dinner table i was always belting
out the most officer krumke and my mom
and dad let me let you know they they
bought the album to play for me and i
memorized all the songs but i'd sit at
the dinner table with my mom and dad
saying my father is a bastard but i mean
i would say bastard you know
as an sob my grandpa's always plastered
my
something's pushing tea my sister wears
a mustache my brother wears a dress my
parents were crying and saying
you can't say sob at the dinner table
you can never say the word bastard again
and i would say but mom dad you gave me
the record why'd you give me the record
if i can't say sob and bastard so
west side story started a lot of rows in
our house earlier
um
watching this film
i was in awe of the shots some of the
camera angle was high then it was low
there was a reflection in the puddle i
know you you spend months planning these
shots and it's truly i think you even
bested yourself but how can you talk
about the complexity of it versus some
of your other films
is it more complex i know there was a
temple of dune opening you know musical
number
but how does that compare to like
a musical doesn't compare a musical
takes such collab collaborative partners
a musical takes a marriage between the
choreographer and the director a musical
involves casting people who can wear
have to wear four hats they have to be
able to sing they have to be able to
dance they have to be able to act and
they have to be able to exist without
doing any of those three things and
still draw your attention in stillness
it's an extraordinary requirement to be
able to earn the the right to perform in
any musical let alone west side story
which is why it took a whole year to
cast the movie for me and for cindy told
my casting director
but i but i also found
that they're a musical just because of
the idiom of that or the genre
it creates such a sister and brotherhood
because people work we've worked four
and a half months in rehearsal i've
never done rehearsals on any film let
alone four and a half months just to
rehearse the dances and and and this and
the scene study
and to get the storyboards i
storyboarded every shot
and i also on my iphone
uh videoed and recorded all the
rehearsals and i got all my camera
angles during that four and a half
months of rehearsal period and i cut all
my little iphone videos together put the
music to it and if i didn't like it i'd
throw it out and start again the next
day so i had a lot of rehearsal
so every time i set up the camera that
the camera
was telling the story it wasn't just
because the shot was cool and because
the angle up high was cool it was
because every shot helps to advance the
story and create a deeper
involvement for the audience to get
emotionally into the storytelling so i
don't think i did anything in west side
story with the camera that was arbitrary
or that was slick at all was in the
service of the story one thousand
percent i want to talk about the late
stephen sondheim i know you you've
talked a little bit about
how you would look to him when he was on
set to know if you got something right i
don't know if that was in rehearsals and
you would almost know more by his
expression can you give me maybe give me
an example of that or or
a moment that really you know you got
his blessing how he felt about the film
and and what that meant to you
well
with the fact that steve was with me
every day during the pre-recording
sessions we recorded all the vocal
artists and stephen was there at the
recording studio sitting next to me
every single day he didn't directly
interface with the with the actors
because that was janine tosuri's job she
was our musical director and he never
interfered with her interpretation but
he i would watch steve's face because he
always listened to the singing with his
eyes closed and he'd be smiling and then
suddenly he'd go
like that because he heard not not a bad
note maybe he heard a pitchy a pitchy
moment and that can always be fixed with
a sec with another take
but he would hear an interpretive
something that didn't interpret the way
he always imagined his words being
interpreted and he would always talk to
me about that
and he would always say to me and to
janine it's very very important that the
actors don't
concentrate on their vocal performance
just get them to concentrate on who
they're playing who these characters are
because if they believe who they are
emotionally and if they get to know
their characters
deeply
the music will be second fiddle to that
don't worry about the music just
understand who you are that was exactly
janine chisori's entire philosophy too
so in that sense steven and geneva are
on the same page but what an honor was
to sit next to steve for three weeks and
then he occasionally came to the set and
hung out with me
and he was such a friend he became a
good friend over the course of four
years and his sudden
loss
was a profound loss to all of us wow we
just didn't expect it i thought he'd
outlive my dad wow um before i go i'm
sort of a two-parter as a last question
first of all if in the future some
director said i want to reimagine one of
steven spielberg's films which film
would you be most interested in seeing
reimagined by maybe a future director
and also about the ritual do you leave
set a day early is that something i
heard that you've done since jaws i
don't know if that's true or not or if i
don't i know i used to leave the set a
day early when it was just like a
special effect going off i didn't have
to be there for but i don't do that
anymore that was my that was in my youth
in my in my in my silly blind youth um
but but the the whole thing about um
what was your question about uh a film
that of yours if somebody was traveling
of mine i i don't know i'd like somebody
i would love someday to somebody to to
remake hook and turn it into a full
musical not me but somebody else and i
wouldn't i wouldn't mind seeing um if
somebody ever remade without me if
somebody ever remade a film like uh
always it was a love story that that
that that didn't get any traction uh but
i really
it meant a lot to me and i'd love to see
that story which was also a remake of a
guy named joe by victor fleming and that
was the original source material for me
those are the two films i'd love someone
else to remake someday life matters
even more than love
[Music]
if i'm not mistaken you've talked a
little bit about working with stephen
and kind of being that fly in a wall and
you said you found it fascinating just
to watch his process from how easy he
finds certain things to even the
challenges so if you could sort of allow
us to be a fly on the wall in what you
experienced
well first of all he's such an
open-hearted person and he he always
leads with his heart and that's that's
so so evident when you first meet him um
clearly there's there's the kind of
shock and awe you have to get past when
you're when you're realizing that you
get a chance to work with this legend
but that goes very way very quick
quickly at least it did for me because
he's he's exceptional at
getting people to kind of uh just get on
the same page and say let's let's do
something let's try to do it the best we
can there are so many examples of of
watching him work that were we're just
such a great education for example
i remember i remember we were shooting a
scene it was a little scene after um
tony and marina come out from behind the
uh the bleachers
and he i think he had storyboarded it
one particular way
and
the the way that the we were going to
shoot that day was proving to be a
little bit more challenging than he
expected and he just very very
matter-of-factly said well sometimes you
think you know how you're going to do it
and then you don't know and and he just
kind of
had to do what he needed to do to get it
done in that moment
and you just realize in those in those
situations that
these are just people who are so good at
what they do
and are dedicated to finding the right
answer and are not afraid to say i don't
know how this work this one works
and because of their skill and their
their
desire to get it right you just watch
them get to work
and uh yeah that to me was just a little
thing that that spoke volumes to me what
was the best note he gave you
tone it down
oh seriously
in one in one scene he's like a little
less a little less uh it was it was a
big scene so so uh he was he was right
about that um
but you know he had all kinds of insight
to krupke that i i used as cornerstones
of of my of my character one of which
was was this this idea of him constantly
having an ulcer he he said he very very
early on he said i think that krupke is
duodenally challenged and it took me a
second to understand what he meant
yes it means the lower intestine and
i.e ulcer um so yeah that that to me i
think is is kind of where his mind was
in terms of setting this character up as
as being someone who's constantly not
only at odds with the job that he had to
do but literally at odds with himself
kind of internally in in complete uh
discomfort about about what was
happening in his world and the other
thing he he said which is another great
little insight is that i think this guy
probably would prefer to be in the back
room filing papers rather than out in in
in the community kind of on the on the
razor's edge of trying to kind of you
know stop these warring warring you know
groups coming together and always trying
to kind of keep them at bay and how
exhausting that was and how scary and
dangerous it is wow those are and it's
interesting because when you're saying
that that was those are specific things
that make your character fascinating and
sort of set it apart and make it a
reimagining of the original being that
you are so esteemed in the broadway
community um could you talk a little bit
about the fact that you were with the
exception of rita probably the most
veteran actor on the set that this is a
lot of young actors that sometimes have
never done a movie before and just that
energy i think you've talked a little
bit about it being around those people
that are on the precipice of this huge
stardom and something huge if you can
kind of talk about that well there's
there's one there's one story that i've
told a couple times that i think
exemplifies the kind of spirit that was
evident on set and uh mind you i i i
spent uh five days uh you know when we
were in the gym shooting dance at the
gym sequence which in my opinion could
be a movie in and of itself yeah so i
felt so lucky to be just watching that
every day
but you have you do have a lot of uh
extraordinary young actors and dancers
who haven't been on film and i'm i'm no
you know expert in in being a film actor
i've done my fair share of them
and i i have an awareness of some of the
things that you do and don't do on a set
one of which is it's kind of it's kind
of not it's not usual for an actor to go
over to what's called video village and
watch a scene
over the director's shoulder and it's
kind of a no-no because that's their
domain and that's their that's where
they get to paint that's their canvas
and you kind of want to let you don't
want to interrupt that
but
but in this film it was so beautiful
because after all these big dance
sequences you'd have 30
young extraordinary people who are just
impossibly talented running over to to
stand behind him and watch watch the
watch what they had just shot and at the
end of it everyone's saying yay just
super excited about what they had just
done and and that to me i think it
really is the lifeblood of this film it
was it was really evident last night at
the screening
the first time i saw it and we had
pretty much the full cast there but the
sense of pride and the sense of of
accomplishment and ability i can't i
can't say this enough
the dancers in this film
i just i'm astounded by what they've
done yeah uh so so that is a um
that is a little story about about about
the community that we that we had making
this film was there a scene where they
were i heard they were messing with you
or something like it was either the jets
or the sharks and you were like is this
a gag
no no i i was convinced that steven
spielberg had had told pulled all of the
jets aside and said listen whenever the
camera isn't rolling please bother brian
as much as you can it turns out they
were just naturally gifted that that
they were all doing their jobs very well
uh even when the camera wasn't we were
all in character and so uh you know
there wasn't a moment when someone
wasn't poking me or stealing my baton or
like untying my shoe or using my hat as
a frisbee it was it was it was
it was constant and i think it really
really helped
you feel that energy and a lot of the
behind the scenes stuff has been as fun
to watch as the film the incredible film
itself um something that i talked to uh
rachel and ansel about yesterday that i
thought was really funny was that when
she was cast in it she was doing shrek
the musical in high school at the time
and said can i just finish it before we
start west side story
having been shrek was that a good move
on her part and were you also did you
also say to stephen hey can i just
finish this before i do your movie or
did you not dare
i was well beyond it uh so so i did i
didn't have the need to kind of say can
i go back and sit in you know make up
for for two and a half hours every day
uh but interestingly janine tesori the
composer of shrek the musical was our
music supervisor and worked with with
you know rachel and ansel and and mike
and ariana and uh is an extraordinary
gifted gifted composer and um
uh uh facilitator of performance so
um yeah i heard that story the other
night and i i joked that you know i i
they wouldn't let me audition for her
version so i was unfortunately i
couldn't play shrek to her fiona
did you do any of the numbers behind the
scenes with rachel did that come up at
all no but maybe maybe that's the next
version of shrek is the
is the live action version
of just
rachel and myself doing it uh somewhere
maybe as a puppet show i don't know i
gotta think this out okay
um being that you are such a veteran of
broadway um i'm gonna ask a broad
question but what is officer krupke and
the story of west side story meant to
you as an actor and an actor of the
theater um over the years and the
tremendous um
gift bestowed on you to play this
beloved character well that's the the
answer part of my answer is in your
question it is a gift it really is
because west side story for me and for
so many people is a cornerstone of my
experience of what it means to um
want to be a part of the the community
that makes musicals that makes theater
that wants to pursue art uh in that
particular way
and uh the standard is so high the bar
is set so high with you know stephen
sondheim's work leonard bernstein's work
jerome robbins work uh arthur lawrence
work the the foundational element of it
not just not to not to forget william
shakespeare uh on which the whole thing
is based so it's it's an extraordinary
thing to be a part of this iteration
where
the history of it is so um palpable to
me
um and that was evident last night with
with original cast members of the movie
who were in attendance which was which
really really was special
and uh and now
now i can say that i am i am you know
carrying the baton along with the rest
of us the cast to try to do our best to
honor and uh and create something new
and exciting which i think we've done i
i heard that um stephen sondheim i don't
know if he worked with him on set but
had some interesting notes and sometimes
steven spielberg would just look to him
to get his reaction and he would know
right there by his reaction
if he they got it right did you have a
personal experience with stephen
sondheim like that no i didn't i didn't
i didn't get to cross paths with him on
set unfortunately um i i had had the
honor of of singing for him and at in a
concert in in dc that marvin hamlisch
was the uh the conductor for with the
with the uh the orchestra there
um
so i was lucky to have that little
interaction with him but um yeah i heard
that story last night and i thought that
was really a great uh a great example of
both of both men in the sense that uh
steven spielberg knew and was was was um
desirous of of stephen sondheim's
reaction to how things were going
whether it was a positive or a negative
and so he was a barometer that he needed
and wanted there um and it's also a
testament to to sondheim and his kind of
what i've come to learn and i'm
constantly learning in in the
unfortunate pat his passing
and sad passing that he was such an
honest
um uh
and and and uh kind of undeniably honest
artist in the sense that
what he wanted to uh
uh explore and uh on earth was not
always pretty and uh and and i'm sure he
was always very honest in his um
in his assessment of things as well uh
to everyone's credit you know
everyone's benefit um so yeah that's
that's a great story of two people kind
of being in the in the boat steering
together
you